Kanye has an unbelievably entertaining  way of talking like whether you like it  or don't like it he is wildly  entertaining like I was watching Alex  Freeman it like I'm watching and I'm  just laughing hey don't say Jewish media  don't say Jewish media JM  dude he has this one thing that he goes  I knew Kim would never love Pete and not  because he's ugly but because she likes  black guys that not because he's ugly is  the most unnecessary thing but that is  him being petty and angry and just throw  he just wants to call Pete ugly yeah do  you know what I'm saying he ain't the  best looking mother  the fact that he put himself with Reggie  Bush but he's like yo she got a chance  [Music]  is towards black people he thinks they  all look the same literally  left out her first husband who looked  nothing like them right because Humphrey  but right here Reggie Bush and me  [Music]